en este vídeo veremos cómo preparar
alumnos de alquilo a partir de alcoholes
si empezamos con este alcohol del lado
izquierdo y le agregamos ssl 2 que es
llamado cloruro de tío nilo y piri dina
vamos a sustituir un átomo de cloro por
el grupo o h
este mecanismo ocurre vía un mecanismo
de tipo s n 2 que significa que sólo va
a funcionar con alcoholes primarios o
secundarios y es posible obtener vamos a
obtener una inversión en la
configuración si tenemos un centro que
ir al presente en el producto final
ahora echemos un vistazo al mecanismo
comenzaremos con nuestro alcohol
entonces el oxígeno va a tener que irse
de alguna manera pero por sí mismo el
wache no es un buen grupo saliente por
lo que haremos reaccionar este alcohol
con el cloruro de tió nilo para
convertirlo en un mejor grupo saliente
si dibujamos la estructura de puntos
para el cloruro de tío ni lo tendríamos
el azufre doblemente enlazado a un
oxígeno aquí y luego el azufre también
está enlazado al cloro voy a dibujar
esos pares de electrones
en los claros así y si cuentan los
electrones de valencia resulta que
necesita dos más y esos van en el azufre
está bien que el azufre viole la regla
del octeto dado que es un elemento del
tercer periodo
un par de electrones disponibles en el
oxígeno va a formar un enlace con el
átomo de azufre el cual pasaría a estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno de arriba
entonces si dibujamos lo que
obtendríamos en el primer paso del
mecanismo vemos que nuestro oxígeno está
unido al azufre
el oxígeno también está unido a un
hidrógeno un par de electrones
disponibles formaron este nuevo enlace
por lo que un par de electrones se queda
atrás lo que daría a este oxígeno una
carga formal de más 1 unido al azufre
este oxígeno de arriba tenía dos pares
de electrones disponibles y tomó un par
de electrones más lo que le da una carga
formal de menos 1 y este azufre sigue
unido al cloro
voy a dibujar estos aquí podemos dibujar
estos pares de electrones disponibles en
el azufre así
en el siguiente paso del mecanismo
volveremos a formar volveremos a formar
ese doble enlace entre oxígeno y azufre
entonces estos electrones van a pasarse
para acá y estos electrones van a irse a
ese cloro y cuando dibujamos el
siguiente el siguiente intermedio aquí
tendríamos ahora nuestro oxígeno
que sigue unido al hidrógeno y sigue
teniendo una carga formal de más 1 y
ahora nuestro azufre está doblemente
unido al oxígeno de nuevo con dos pares
de electrones disponibles en el oxígeno
y el azufre también está unido a un solo
cloro uno de los claros se fue
podemos dibujar el cloro que se fue
entonces uno de los cloro se fue y es
una unión cloruro cargado negativamente
y sigue habiendo un par de electrones
disponibles en el azufre así en esta
parte del mecanismo la piri dina hace su
aparición dibujaremos la estructura de
puntos de la piscina
es una base
que se parece a un anillo de benceno
excepto que tiene un nitrógeno aquí y
habrá un par de electrones disponibles
en este nitrógeno y ese par de
electrones disponibles va a funcionar
como una base de bronx de lo gris y
tomará este protón de aquí en el oxígeno
y eso va a pasar estos electrones de
regreso a este oxígeno
entonces vamos a dibujarlo vamos a
buscar un poco de espacio aquí entonces
que obtendríamos tendríamos ahora a
nuestro carbono unido a nuestro oxígeno
el oxígeno ahora tiene dos pares de
electrones disponibles a su alrededor y
tenemos el azufre
el cloro
y nuestro par de electrones disponibles
en el azufre y ahora hemos creado un
mejor grupo saliente este es un mejor
grupo saliente de lo que era él
al principio y si pensamos en un
mecanismo tipo s n 2
sabemos que el enlace carbono oxígeno
está polarizado si el oxígeno es más
electro negativo y será parcialmente
negativo y este carbono de aquí será
parcialmente positivo el carbono será
parcialmente positivo
y ahora podemos pensar en nuestro
mecanismo tipo s n 2 nuestro núcleo filo
será este año en cloruro de arriba que
formamos en el mecanismo éste será el
núcleo filo y va a atacar a nuestro
carbón o parcialmente positivo un
mecanismo tipo s n 2 y mientras de
cloruro ataca todo el lado derecho se va
a salir entonces los electrones en
magenta se van a mover hacia acá y luego
estos electrones van a pasarse hacia ese
cloro cuando dibujamos el producto
podemos mostrar que el cloro se ha unido
a nuestro carbono en el lado izquierdo y
en el lado derecho si siguen el
movimiento de esos electrones van a
formar dióxido de azufre
2 y también el avión cloruro
cl
- así
lo hemos hecho hemos sustituido nuestro
átomo de cloro por el h y formamos una
luro de alquilo ésta es sólo una mejor
manera de formar un cloruro de alquilo a
partir de un alcohol veamos un ejemplo
vamos a usar un alcohol como etanol y si
hacemos reaccionar el etanol con cloruro
de dioni lo s o cl2 y tenemos piri dina
como base vamos a reemplazar el h con
nuestro cloro así y una vez más si
observamos al alcohol es un alcohol
primario y los alcoholes primarios son
los que mejor funcionan ya que hay menor
impedimento estético
no nos preocuparemos por la estéreo
química ya que no tenemos centros
quirales en nuestro producto
veamos ahora una manera de formar
bromuro de alc y lo acabamos de formar
un cloruro de alc y lo veamos la
reacción general para formar un bromuro
de alquilo tengo mi alcohol aquí y luego
reaccionar con three bromuro de fósforo
ddr3 y voy a obtener el grupo o h va a
irse
y voy a colocar un bromo en su lugar
y nuevamente este mecanismo es un
mecanismo tipo s n 2 sólo para alcoholes
primarios o secundarios y posible
inversión de la configuración en los
productos dependiendo en si tenemos
centros espirales presentes o no
entonces otro mecanismo es n 2 y de
nuevo necesitamos usar el tri bromuro de
fósforo porque el grupo o h no es un
buen grupo saliente cuando vemos este
mecanismo vamos a dibujar este par de
electrones disponibles así y tenemos
three bromuro de fósforo voy a dibujar
la estructura de puntos tendríamos estos
bramos aquí con pares de electrones
disponibles
esos bromo y debemos de seguir teniendo
en cuenta dos electrones de valencia más
que irían en nuestro fósforo así
el primer paso es análogo a nuestro
mecanismo anterior el par de electrones
disponibles en el oxígeno va a formar un
enlace con el fósforo y eso llevaría a
estos electrones hacia uno de los bromo
y yo escogí ese no importa cual bromo
sea y cuando vemos el resultado de esto
tendríamos ahora a nuestro oxígeno unido
al fósforo el oxígeno sigue unido a un
hidrógeno
y sigue habiendo un par de electrones
disponibles en el oxígeno lo que le da a
este oxígeno una carga formal de más 1
y el fósforo está ahora unido a dos
bromas únicamente
dibujaremos el fósforo unido a solo 2
gramos
voy a dibujar estos aquí y puedo poner
un par de electrones disponibles en el
fósforo también entonces perdimos un
bromo y eso formó una neón bromuro vamos
a dibujar nuestro unión
bromuro aquí
y nuevamente hemos creado un mejor grupo
saliente todo esto de la derecha es un
mejor grupo saliente que lo h y ahora
podemos pensar en nuestro mecanismo tipo
s n 2 en el que de nuevo el carbono este
carbono de aquí va a ser electro físico
por lo que quiere electrones cargados
negativamente que puede obtener de la
neón bromuro hay un ataque núcleo físico
y eso pasaría estos electrones de aquí
hacia el oxígeno y ahora vamos a dibujar
nuestros productos
cuando dibujamos el producto todo lo que
tenemos que hacer es mostrar que hemos
hecho una sustitución el bromo está
ahora unido al carbono así y el otro
producto sería un hidrógeno unido a un
oxígeno y el oxígeno estaría unido a un
fósforo y el fósforo está unido a dos
promos así
hemos formado un bromuro de al kilo
vamos a ver un ejemplo rápidamente
comenzaremos de nuevo con etanol si
quisiéramos convertir etanol en bromuro
de etilo todo lo que debemos hacer es
añadir three bromuro de fósforo así y
por supuesto vamos a reemplazar el h con
un bromo ese es un modo de preparar
haluros de alquiló a partir de alcoholes